life evolved on our planet about 4.1
billion years ago
at that time there were no complex
organisms
trees or any other life forms as we know
them
our blue planet was a gloomy and hot
place
almost incapable of sustaining life
in order for the situation to change it
took the earth
going through the formation of
continents an atmosphere rich in oxygen
and oceans to create favorable
conditions
for the evolution of multicellular life
forms
but what if something similar happened
elsewhere in the universe
there are 11 confirmed earth-like
exoplanets within
50 light-years alone from the solar
system
and most of them remain to be discovered
yet
what can these potentially habitable
worlds look like
and how similar are they to our planet
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
several centuries ago it was quite
unimaginable to admit of discovering
exoplanets
however everything changed in 1992 as
the polish astronomer alexander vostin
was studying the pulsar psr 1257 plus 12
it was noticed that its pulsation period
was irregular
which was accounted for by the influence
of two planets with a mass
four times that of our earth this
hypothesis was later confirmed
which led to the conclusion that the
first planetary system beyond
ours had been discovered there are three
objects in that system
two of which have a mass similar to that
of the earth and are comparatively close
to their pulsar in the constellation
virgo
due to the fact that it is rather remote
from us and the conditions for
sustaining life are poor
the psr 1257 plus 12
system is of little interest to
scientists although its discovery led us
to believe
that the search for earth-like worlds
may eventually be a success
just three years later the first
exoplanet orbiting a sun-like star was
discovered
50 light years away from the earth and
was dubbed
51 pega cb just
several years later the number of
confirmed
exoplanets counted dozens and today
4173 exoplanets
in 3096 different planetary systems
unknown to science in addition a great
number of earth-like objects
is still awaiting the confirmation of
their status
which is possible after a secondary
registration with telescopes on earth
the number of celestial objects of this
kind in the entire milky way
may well be over a hundred billion with
about one-fifth of them
bearing resemblance to our earth
interestingly
most of the discovered earth-like
exoplanets
are located not very far from our system
ros-128b this planet
was discovered in 2017 by european
scientists
with the help of the high accuracy
radial velocity planet searcher
or halves at the observatory in chile
the object is located in the single star
system ros 128
which is the 13th closest star to us
the object is a faint red dwarf with a
mass of 0.15 that of the sun
it was possible to discover this planet
thanks to its gravity
which leads to minor variations of the
stellar spectrum of its parent star
while observing these variations harps
is able to spot planets around stars
in this particular case it took the
telescope approximately 10 years to
collect sufficient data
before discovering this planet this
effort
paid off ros 128b
became the second earth-like exoplanet
lying closest to us
it is located 11 light years away from
the earth
in the constellation virgo apart from
that
astronomers claim it to be the most
moderate of all known exoplanets
due to its mass its temperature and its
rather calm parent star
it takes this planet 10 days to orbit
its star
it finds itself in the habitable zone
since the temperature of the photosphere
and luminosity of ros 128 are low
it is also classified as an earth-like
type of planet
and at the moment ross 128 b
is one of the most likely candidates to
be a potentially habitable exoplanet
besides research done in 2018 confirmed
that its climate is favorable enough to
sustain life
another exoplanet on the list of
earth-like objects located
closest to us is gliese 667cc
this celestial body is part of the
triple star stellar system gliese
667 in the constellation scorpius
it consists of two orange dwarves and
one red dwarf
the first two components a and b lie
12.6 astronomical units from each other
with the third component
orbiting them at a distance of 203
astronomical units the earth-like planet
in this system
was discovered on november the 29th 2011
in the geneva observatory with the help
of the doppler method
the object is 22.7 light years away from
the earth
and is the second exoplanet orbiting its
host
star the mass of gliese 667cc
is about 3.8 times that of the earth
while its temperature range may be
rather similar to the terrestrial one
modeling at the planetary habitability
laboratory
managed by university of puerto rico
reveals
that the average surface temperature of
the atmosphere of gliese
667cc must be approximately 27 degrees
celsius the planet receives about 90
percent of energy
compared to that received by the earth
from the sun
also gliese 667cc is almost
certain to be locked in its orbit that
is it faces its star with one on the
same side
if the planet's orbit does not curve too
little and if its mass is not too big
the greenhouse effect produced by the
rather dense atmosphere
must be quite sufficient to create
favorable conditions
for primitive life forms
the next deserving object in our list is
hd85512
an exoplanet orbiting the orange dwarf
hd-85512
in the constellation velar its star
is a single k-type main sequence star
with the mass 0.69 that of our sun
as for its age it is more than 5.6
billion years old
the exoplanet discovered close to it
is located 36 light years away from the
earth
and its mass is 3.6 times that of our
planet
at the same time hd 85512b
may be one of the smallest planets in
the habitable zone
it was spotted in august 2011 with a
harps telescope
the supposed steady state temperature of
its surface
is something around 25 degrees celsius
if the planet's atmosphere is identical
to that of the earth
its surface temperature should reach 78
degrees
celsius it is also highly probable that
there is liquid water on this celestial
body
which is why for some time it was
believed to become the most
likely place where life would be
discovered first
apart from the objects mentioned there
is a number of other celestial bodies in
space
located quite close to us which also
boasts
some unique features many of them may
well contain
various life forms and maybe not quite
as far from us
as we would imagine however we should
bear in mind that some half a century
ago
man did not possess a tenth of
information known to us today
and in the future the progress of our
discoveries
is going to escalate even more
dramatically
for example on december the 18th 2019
the k-ops space telescope was
successfully launched in orbit
by the european space agency it is
specifically aimed at exploring
exoplanets
using the transit method it may be this
spacecraft is to contribute to the list
of earth-like exoplanets
and it may become the telescope to first
discover alien life forms in the
universe
science does not stand still and every
new day
bears witness to the fact that mankind
continues to actively stride forward
if this progress does not lose its
momentum sooner or later we are bound to
find an answer to the eternal mind
perturbing question
are we alone in the universe and i hope
the answer we get will prove that
life is not a mere accident but a
logical consequence of the evolution
in our universe
[Music]
you